subways are a phenomenal way to provide
cheap
and efficient transportation within
densely populated urban cores
though the new york subway has recently
been on a downward spiral
this has less to do with the system
itself and
more to do with certain people who are
using it despite this
elon musk has a different vision for the
future of
underground travel which includes using
a network of smaller tunnels and cars
as opposed to the regular train-like
system and
though this is quite a simple idea in
theory
boring tunnels have the potential to
destroy subways
in terms of cost and efficiency and
here's why
well starting off the most glaring
difference between regular subways
and boring tunnels is the size of the
tunnels themselves
boring tunnels are significantly smaller
than regular subways
which allows for exponentially lower
construction costs
so far the boring company has been
digging tunnels that are 14 feet in
diameter
however the construction of the tunnel
takes up two feet
which leaves 12 feet in internal
diameter subway tunnels on the other
hand
are generally about 20 feet in diameter
and assuming that the structure of the
tunnel more or less scales up
proportionately with the diameter
we'll say that the walls of the tunnel
bring down the internal diameter by
three feet to about 17 feet if we do a
bit of math
we can figure out that boring tunnels
require approximately 40 cubic feet of
concrete
for each foot of tunnel meanwhile subway
tunnels require over double that
at 87 cubic feet and when you factor in
additional costs of building a subway
such as lane tracks electric lines and
power stations
you can see how this would get expensive
very quickly
the boring company's tunnels cost 10
million dollars per mile
according to their website this sounds
pretty high already
until you realize that the average
subway tunnel construction
in the u.s costs anywhere between 200
and 500 million dollars per mile or 20
to 50 times higher
we even have subways that cost upwards
of one billion dollars per mile
mainly in california but even that pales
in comparison to certain subways in new
york
which cost a whopping 2.6 billion
dollars per mile
europe and japan are much better than
the us
in terms of cost efficiency as they both
come in
at about 100 million dollars per mile
but
that's still 10 times the boring tunnel
anyways
coming back to the united states even
estimating on the lower end of the range
at 300 million dollars per mile new york
city's 665 miles of track
clocks in at an eye-watering 200
billion dollars for that same cost
the boring company could have built 20
000 miles of tunnels
that's nearly half the size of the
entire us
interstate highway system which comes in
at 46
876 miles and keep in mind
that's just from the cost of the
construction of the subway tunnels
in new york city alone i think that
really needs no further explanation
so the cost of construction of boring
tunnels are
exponentially cheaper than the cost of
construction of subways
which makes building a boring network
much easier
but that's not it what about the subway
stations themselves
the boring company doesn't need any
subway stations
as they simply have rising platforms
which can directly take you into the
network
they are offering a sub-service station
option
but this is just one of the options to
enter their boring network
and they are by no ways limited to
underground stations
like traditional subways this eliminates
the need to excavate millions of cubic
feet
every several miles and build escalators
and restrooms and walkways
and all the associated maintenance i
think you get the point
new york subway stations have
construction costs in the hundreds of
millions
with figures ranging from 347 million
to 812 million and it doesn't really
matter how much the average boring
platform costs
as it's no doubt just a fraction of this
so
it's no question that the boring company
destroys subways
on an exponential level from an
economical perspective
but cost isn't everything people are
often willing to pay premium prices
for premium services but unfortunately
i don't think we can really classify
subway stations as a premium service
at least not in the us generally
u.s subway stations are at best a
mediocre service
it should be noted however that they're
extremely cheap
but anyways moving on to non-economical
benefits of the boring system
we have convenience with boring tunnels
you can take your own private vehicles
into the tunnel meaning that you don't
even have to walk
to and from the station but even if you
are just using the system as a
pedestrian
it's quite likely that a boring entry
point will be closer to your starting
point
and destination as they can easily be
built across the city
of course this is no doubt a first world
problem
but still a benefit nonetheless aside
from convenience
we also have speed of transportation
subway trains
generally only travel at 40 to 50 miles
per hour
not to mention the constant stops which
brings down the overall travel speed
to just 15 or 20 miles per hour the
boring company on the other hand
is aiming to offer speeds of anywhere
between 125
and 150 miles per hour also
traffic won't be an issue as all the
vehicles are expected to be autonomous
a regular single lane freeway can handle
about 2 200 human drivers per hour
but when we throw ai into the mix it's
expected that this number will grow by
at least 3x
so though boring tunnels are only one
lane roads
they can handle the same capacity as
three-lane freeways
and potentially even more moreover with
the boring tunnels
you can choose to enter at any point and
exit at any point
and skip all the exits in the middle if
you choose a pedestrian option however
you may have to deal with stops in the
middle but
this is likely still far less than the
number of stops
in a regular subway the thing is the
boring buses
are quite small in the first place so
they're forced to tend to the needs of
new shrouds
and customers as opposed to serving a
generic market
thus the regular boring loop is a
cost-effective
convenient and fast method of travel
within
and around cities but this isn't the
only thing coming out of the boring
company
their most exciting endeavor is no doubt
the hyperloop
the hyperloop is essentially the same
thing as the regular boring loop
the difference is simply that the
hyperloop will be in a vacuum chamber
thus eliminating the effects of air
resistance which allows for
ultra high speeds of even over 600 miles
per hour
so we're basically dealing with an
underground jet
and as no energy is wasted and gaining
altitude
we can travel from point to point even
more efficiently
we will probably see the emergence of
some pretty useful routes
such as from washington dc to baltimore
or new york
but the more significant use case of
hyperloops
may be in conjunction with spacex's
starship rockets
if you haven't heard yet spacex is
planning on using their new rocket
starship to provide extremely rapid
point-to-point travel
within the earth as in less than 30
minutes for most long-distance routes
however one drawback to the system is
that most of the launch facilities will
be on the ocean
as the rockets simply make too much
noise for daily inland use
as a result this is a perfect
opportunity to use hyperloops
as hyperloops can offer quick travel
between launch facilities
and large inland cities so that may be
what we are looking at when it comes to
the long-term future goals of the boring
company
but let's be real here when will such
projects
even take place and become open to the
public
well currently it's not even close to
becoming a reality
in june of this year the boring company
actually completed two tunnels
in las vegas but they're only
one mile long each and though they will
become open to the public
in january of 2021 the top speed is
currently
only 35 miles per hour despite faster
speeds being demonstrated
aside from this the system will also not
take advantage of autonomous driving
slides initially
and it will rely on human drivers in the
boring company's defense
they haven't even been around for a full
four years yet
and such infrastructure takes decades to
get approval for
and slowly build up with that being said
we may see some major routes opening up
as well as regular loop service for
major cities
by the 2030s however serious adoption
and implementation of the idea won't
take place until well into the 2030s
and 2040s but though elon's timelines
are usually way too ambitious he usually
does eventually deliver
so let's hope that this is the same case
with the boring company
will you guys be using boring loops or
do you just plan on sticking to
autopilot and traditional highways
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys are excited for the future
of public transportation
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but
until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one